in dieser Woche ist es nun soweit der
41-Jährige Ostwestfalen ist ein wenig
aufgeregt denn die meisten haben hier
noch nie einen Bielefelder gesehen
es geht los
[Musik]
erste ernährungsversuche wird noch ein
wenig hölzern und natürlich muss ja auch
nicht jeden persönlich begrüßen dennoch
kommt der schnell ins Gespräch
[Musik]
würde heute endlich mal in die Karnevals
Welt eintauchen
aber da müssen sie in den Pausen mal
hier bisschen die Frauen betrachten und
die haben schon was getrunken dann ist
das gut weil ja weil du dann lustig sind
entscheiden
D
freigegeben und dann bist du auf jeden
Fall dabei gibt es ein Kostüm das an
Karneval gar nicht geht es geht alles
Karneval absolut auch Cowboy hier in
Köln geht ja sicher und gerade
geht aber bitte nicht so oder
[Musik]
ab der Karim ist fasziniert eine ganz
neue Welt tut sich für ihn auf Menschen
werden durch die Luft geschleudert und
schnell trifft er auch auf den ein oder
anderen mit Migrationshintergrund extra
aus Berlin hierher warum um mir Karneval
erklären zu lassen und das ist normalen
Weg ich bin Bielefelder wollte Karneval
hier verstehen aber irgendwie
schwierig das auf einen Satz zu bringen
was wurde dir gesagt was ist wichtig
naja zumindestens Kostüm hast du ja auch
geschafft also schon mal klasse und man
muss diese dünne Bier mögen aber habt
ihr denn so einen Satz
können muss damit ich hier Leute
beeindrucken kann
sofort nach Köln komme und du weißt auf
Deutsch
aber klingt schön
hast du ein zwei goldene Tipps für mich
jedes Getränk was einem angeboten wird
mit trinken
ja dann jedes Getränk was man bekommt ja
es gibt zwei ja und dann
auch Alkohol hat hier eine lange
Tradition man versteht die Leute danach
einfach besser
[Applaus]
der Bielefelder macht Fortschritte
schnell findet abdelanschluss
[Musik]
[Applaus]
an und abonniert den Kanal danke
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an und
abonniert den Kanal danke
oh nein eine Zeitschleife habt ihr etwa
nicht den Kanal abonniert Hilfe sofort
draufklicken oder ich bin hier für immer
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an